bitcoin is a decentralized network it
may not be the fastest or the cheapest i
think it's pretty fast and cheap but
anyway just to just just the calm that
appease the haters but it's the most
secure it has never been hacked it has
never been taken down the u.s government
would have taken it down if it could by
now as with russia and so on and so on
once you understand bitcoin it's not
just about understanding it it's about
it goes into every aspect of your life
right yes so the idea of bitcoin is
decentralization proof of work don't
trust verify for example if i'm going to
go rent an airbnb right i now have this
mentality of my head of like don't trust
verify like make sure it's got enough
ratings make sure that you've got a
backup plan it's everything and then of
course it's you've got to take personal
responsibility over your private keys
which then empowers you to start taking
personal responsibility in other areas
of your life you know if you're going to
start working with someone make sure you
know who the [ __ ] they are the leia fun
show